everybody says grasses are food grasses
our clothes there's some ownership and
some sense you know everybody sense
everybody feels when dating Wassa Wassa
community conservation area is a special
project director of
[Music]
in many ways the glossa conservation
efforts are a very conservative kind of
cultural relic and also one that's very
progressive from an outsider's
perspective the local community is
taking ownership of who has access to
this place and when the guava itself has
been around for hundreds of years as a
pseudo protected area there's a long
history going back to various different
legends of its founding but in short it
exists as it does because it's very
difficult to grow crops at this altitude
and at this exposure and the local
community have realized this and kind of
set it aside as a community resource
that they harvest occasionally when you
conserve the wildlife you will conserve
the habitats just when you conserve the
habitats and you will provide some
important inputs for the long-term
sustainability for the community I mean
there will be more water there'll be
less degradation but when this conserved
like this and they can get more benefits
they can take the grass once per two
years or three years and it will be more
advantageous it is sustainable you know
if they can use it for four generations
but if it is open and they can use it
very freely and everything can be
destroyed within a week or two all
things are made by the community and the
comments are living together and each
community ties transfers to the next
generation so I think we also have very
very bright future
you
[Music]